it's a well-worn path from the White
House four of the last five presidents
have visited Northern Ireland each
pledging America's help in preserving
peace
make sure the Irish Accords and the
Windsor agreements stay in place keep
the peace
Joe Biden welcomed the UK's deal with
the EU on post-brexit trailing
arrangements and his presence could help
restore power sharing according to the
first Minister designate at usually
important given the year that we're in
you know because the Americans have such
skin in the game if you like they were
part of bringing about the Good Friday
agreement so I think to come this year
is hugely significant particularly given
that they're very much focused on the
next 25 years they're focused on
economic investment here so they really
want to look towards the future as do we
Bill Clinton was the first U.S president
to make the trip to Belfast marking the
terrorist ceasefires at Christmas 1995.
Hillary and I thank you from the bottom
of our hearts for making us feel so very
very welcome in Belfast and Northern
Ireland
and they've just kept coming since
America came to express its support for
the Good Friday agreement at every
opportunity and to those who choose the
path of peace I promise you the United
States of America
will support you but not everyone has
chosen that path it's still a fragile
pace and there's a massive Security
operation in place the threat level in
Northern Ireland has risen from
substantial to severe meaning a
terrorist attack is deemed highly likely
the threat isn't directed against the
president himself but his visit takes
place against a backdrop of dissident
Republicans targeting police and there
will be a significant increase in the
number of them deployed operationally
while he's in Northern Ireland
each key location will have been
thoroughly searched and locked down says
Jim gamble a former assistant chief
Constable at the end of the day you
don't need to be particularly
sophisticated to disrupt an event like
this it's as cheap as a phone call so
you've got to be confident that if an
anonymous threat comes in and that the
security precautions that you put in
place are sufficiently tight that you
can say that's not possible
he'll spend most of the week in the
Republic of Ireland the ties Run Deep
between the two Nations 40 million
Americans claiming Irish descent but
this is personal for Joe Biden he'll
revisit his ancestral Homeland live and
Mayo where he's guaranteed Miller
falcher a hundred thousand welcomes
David Blevins Sky News in Belfast